infield out fils fera pitching vous ne
comprenez rien ces stagiaires eux vont
tout comprendre
ils participent à un stage de baseball
pendant les vacances motivés ils
viennent s'améliorer il y en a toujours
besoin on apprend toujours des choses
surtout quand les coaches je viens de
vient du canada afin canada etats unis y
ont fait leur fait la malle gagnent donc
c est ça reste des références donc on
peut en profiter dès comment dire des
petits conseils qui peuvent donner
c'était mike ont voyagé je crois pour
mieux pratiquer ce sport des clips
dérivé du cricket les falcons il met un
petit accent québécois le sport si ces
véhicules de belles valeurs
mais c'est important aussi qui aide les
changes entre ces joueurs là c'est une
permettre d'échanger entre les
entraîneurs et les joueurs
entre les joueurs aussi ça permet
d'échanger des idées et de l'information
et faut pas oublier que le baseball en
france une petite fédération qui fait
que ben si ce prêt est petit pourquoi
pas est tous copains copains copines la
casquette vissée sur la tête
labat à la main même les femmes s'y
mettent il faut être un peu fou pour
venir faire du baseball avec des garçons
l'a un peu nous revient pour progresser
et pour justement me permettre moi je
fais du softball en fait et je suis venu
pour essayer de m'intégrer dans une
équipe de baseball dans mon club
le baseball progressent peu en nombre de
licenciés en france on compte quatre
clubs en région centre val de loire avec
les falcons de bourges comme seul
représentant du berry